uh i was going to tell the story of
seeing the old guy fall off the scooter
i hope he's all right jesus christ you
helped him though
what was i supposed to do was the first
person there billy bird of the rescue
[ __ ] guy rolling down the street
sliding on his face
terrible [ __ ] up he wasn't he had
raspberries he knocked himself out he
came around he was spitting up
he was pulling out little bits of teeth
and i don't know why
it was horrifying when i saw it but now
i can't talk about it without laughing
it's just because he was on a scooter i
basically
i was um i'm not going to say all the
information because god forbid
the people that are related to them are
listening so the [ __ ] dude
was like uh ah [ __ ] it i'll just tell
the story
i didn't do anything i just finished
flying
just exploited his [ __ ] tragic action
nobody knows what all right
i i just done finished flying
right which everybody says is so [ __ ]
unsafe right
fly around and look at all this cool
[ __ ] fly over silver lake to see that
they took the water out of it i didn't
realize that and i came back
i [ __ ] land you know say goodbye to
everybody and i'm driving out
you know to the real scary thing driving
down the [ __ ] street i literally
pull out i make a right turn and i don't
i don't drive more than 40 yards and i
just see this [ __ ]
i just this old guy takes the turn
to come onto the on the little two-lane
highway that i'm on he's on the opposite
side of the road and he like
he went too fast and on like a
motorcycle you can't just turn the front
wheel you're going to go down on a
scooter you know what i mean you got to
kind of look your way through the turn
and lean and your momentum momentum you
know he's supposed to look through the
[ __ ] turn he
he was going too fast and he went into
the
the [ __ ] island in the middle
he [ __ ] he jumped the [ __ ] curb
the whole [ __ ] scooter went up in the
back
and he high sided right he just gets
launched off this [ __ ] thing and he's
rolling down the street like a [ __ ]
log why are you laughing so hard because
people falling down is [ __ ] hilarious
he was fine
he didn't break anything he just knocked
himself out he's a little concussed
and then he wasn't wearing a shield and
in the end he just sort of he was
sliding on his face
so i'm going oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] as
i'm watching it and i [ __ ] pull over
no i made sure everybody stopped and i
got out i was like dude dude i just stay
there you're all right
you're all right and um and he was like
he wasn't saying anything in his [ __ ]
raspberry on his face his pants were
torn up he literally got [ __ ]
attacked by a wild animal
and he's [ __ ] lame i feel terrible
that this happened to him but it's just
afterwards
it's just funny and he was laying there
right and like one of his legs he had
like up
like he was chilling and the other one
was just straight out like that he was
like
he was like coming around and i was like
all right man i called 9-1 you're fine
you're fine and then this lady shows up
and she just kept going don't move
don't move okay you're okay just don't
move okay
and she kept going okay and it started
annoying me and i almost started
laughing like i want to be like lady
like the way you're talking is probably
worse than what the [ __ ] he's feeling
right now
so by then you know like five or six
people had stopped everybody called so
this ambulance shows up like okay thank
god
and he and now he wants to get up we
just kept telling him not to get up and
um the ambulance pulls up and he just
goes uh he goes is he all right is he
all right you're like yeah yeah
he seems to be okay you know we're not
[ __ ] doctors but he seems to be okay
and he goes all right just tell him not
to move i already have someone on this
ambulance
there's another one coming and then he
gets the ambulance and drives away
yeah and then we're looking down the
street we don't see any ambulance coming
we're like what the [ __ ]
and um finally one
a cop finally came up and this guy was
[ __ ] priceless he gets out right
[ __ ] horseshoe bald guy right he's
got the whole landing strip he just
comes out looking like sergeant riker
from the rookies for anybody's old
and he [ __ ] just comes walking you
like the guy from nypd blue the old guy
showed his ass with the mustache
minus the mustache he just comes walking
up and he just walks right up to the guy
dennis franz yeah he just walks up
like his toes are almost touching the
guy's body and he just looks down at him
he goes
you all right
and the guy at that point is going like
yeah yeah i'm fine
and he goes all right all right
ambulance is going to be coming like he
just his level of just like i mean he
must be like people would be on fire
every day yeah this guy exactly
he just sees a scooter and this guy
[ __ ] up he's just like yeah yeah all
right he also seemed way too old to
still be in a patrol car
so i think he [ __ ] up somehow and got
busted down or maybe he was on his way
to some uh
senior police [ __ ] banquet or some
[ __ ] and he says
i'm driving the cruiser they know i'm a
cop i have to stop so once that was fine
it was funny
then we're just standing there waiting
for the ambulance but you know we got to
get on with that day
and uh me and there was this tall older
black dude standing there and
he's just like it's like all right man
they're here and i was like yeah yeah
they're here and we just
we both got in the car and [ __ ] drove
away
and uh it was really you know it wasn't
too bad i mean it wasn't too gory a
scene it was just a couple of
raspberries and stuff glad he didn't
have a but it was a serious injury oh
yeah absolutely but it wasn't until
i got on the highway and i started
driving and i started thinking about it
and i just started laughing
i think it was just more the surprise
that that you saw it
but there is just something just
watching somebody get
[ __ ] up like that i remember the time
i was in griffith park and that dude
came down the hill in street clothes on
a skateboard
he went down that [ __ ] what are you
serious dude this kid where you hike
will you hike up to the observatory
somebody was going down yeah uh
a skateboard yeah so i was just north of
where the greek theater was and this guy
just went yeah
went flying by on this thing and i was
just like oh my god that guy
is the [ __ ] like and i'm thinking like
well how's he gonna stop because this is
just downhill to get into traffic and
all of a sudden his legs start doing
that
wobbly [ __ ] thing and i'm like no
[ __ ] way and i'm telling you this guy
was going like [ __ ] 30 miles an hour
and then he just steps off the
skateboard you always do that either one
or two steps and then you're done he was
going so fast
he did like one step and it was like
who's that guy who [ __ ] jumped 30
feet in 1969 nobody ever broke it
he [ __ ] head first yeah
flying it was like the greatest stunt i
ever saw
he landed too and he started rolling nia
when i tell you this guy this guy was
rolling so fast he was like a blur he's
like
he would go like he hit like his elbow
which would shoot him in the air
and then the best is when you're not
going fast enough to keep rolling and
then you just slide in the sand like
all the way down the thing and i was
just like
and the skateboard kept going and i
would and he was
and he just he was just not moving
and i was going like oh my god and he
was so
he started wiping out like 50 yards away
from me and i swear to god it was a
quarter mile walk to get where the [ __ ]
he stopped
and he was just laying in the road not
moving like i was like i think this guy
is [ __ ]
dead he had he had no helmet he had
street clothes on
he looked like he just came back from
drinking and he just had like this
harrison ford like brown leather jacket
he just [ __ ] launched himself
so i get up so i i'm getting close to it
at this point he's trying to set up
he knows he's laying in the middle of
the road and i finally see his
skateboard hit the curb on the other
side
and bounce into a parked car and then he
like like crawled he tried to stand up
and he couldn't put any weight in his
leg and he crawled
he crawled over and sat down and by then
i knew he was all right so i was already
starting to laugh
so i was just going like doing that dude
while laughing
i got you all right he goes he's like
yeah bro
what the [ __ ] man i was just going
and at that point i'm trying out the lap
i was just like dude i go that was
[ __ ]
that was [ __ ] hardcore man i never
seen a wipeout like that if i was
filming that [ __ ] thing dude it was
the most [ __ ]
it was the greatest log roll whatever
the [ __ ] you call that thing that dude
was just
i never seen it i can't believe his
shoes stayed on like
you know your shoes always fly off
whenever you get hit real hard yeah
oh my god tremendous [ __ ] tremendous
and it's just as much as you feel for
the person there's just nothing funnier
than watching somebody [ __ ] wipe out
if they don't die and you don't know
them right
god god help me man so anyways let me
get um
let's get to the story here so anyways
yeah me and uh
you know paul versi and a couple other
buddies of ours started you know go to
these big college games every year so
we assumed you know we went to the house
that it was just going to be the four of
us
right four or five that's what i thought
it was going to be and we show up to
this house and it was
the four or five of us plus like i don't
i don't even know how many other guys
were staying there
turns out this place like this beer
company rented it out
so we didn't have to kick any money in
and then they stocked the fridge with
all their beer
and then all their [ __ ] that doesn't
sell like all those ciders and all that
[ __ ] horse [ __ ]
um so and then all those other guys that
we didn't know
also invited some other people and it
was like [ __ ] i don't know like 12
people in the house
it was [ __ ] hilarious like i was
literally went in there
i had no idea who was who who was
staying who was friends of people
staying
right sort of that shady type of thing
there's not a lock on your door you're
like thinking i got a computer in there
there's sunglasses what the [ __ ]
are these people cool you have no idea
who anybody is i felt like i was unlike
the [ __ ]
like if the real world did like an over
40 episode of their show like that's
what it felt like um
fortunately everybody turned out to be
uh
like totally cool but um i gotta tell
you there was one [ __ ] morning though
that was so goddamn hilarious
uh what's his face paul verzi as i've
told you before
i've told you this [ __ ] before on other
podcasts that paul versi
not only is not a morning person
he might be like the biggest like
non-morning person i think i have ever
met
in my life like the [ __ ] look on his
face
when when he gets woken up before he
feels he should be woken up i swear to
god
i can't even describe the it's like he
looks like he's walking out of court
and he just lost the case and he was 100
percent right and he's already mentally
he's mentally getting past that
and thinking about how he's going to
take justice into his own hands
you know like he's going to [ __ ]
somebody
that's if you wake him up 20 minutes
early right
so we're in this [ __ ] house all right
and everybody in there
is a married guy all right and uh for
you youngsters out there i don't know if
you've ever partied with like married
guys like
truly married guys like me and virzie
are married but like you know we go on
the road like every other week every
other week
you know you get some r r you walk away
from it
but these guys truly married guys those
guys that [ __ ] wake up
wife and kids right
get in the car go to work come back home
wife and kids wake up the next day
wife and kids and all the [ __ ] that
comes with that right susie chipped her
tooth on the
coffee table and don't forget mikey's
t-ball game and uh there's a dance
recital
jesus christ right [ __ ]
get in the car go to work coming home
can you pick up some more [ __ ]
yeast whatever what the [ __ ] you gotta
do
come home wife and kids you get the deal
those [ __ ] guys
when they go away and they get three
days like you'll never see somebody go
[ __ ]
they'll drink college kids under the
table these guys were [ __ ] animals
i almost gave them a standing ovation
the level with which that they would
they would like drink until like three
four o'clock in the morning
and then they would be up again at like
9 a.m the same [ __ ] guys
which is no big deal if you're a
youngster but these guys are in their
40s
that's not done that's like daryl green
still running at 440 when he was like 41
years old
this is the alcoholic version of it
right so what was hilarious was they had
surround sound
in that house so like
you know late at night when they had the
music on like i went to go to bed and
it's [ __ ]
cranked in my room but fortunately
there's a volume that you have you go
and you turn and you shut it off
so anyway so we all go to bed at like
three four o'clock in the [ __ ]
morning the first night all right
and um i got to be up early because i
got to punch up this script for this
week i got two three hours of work that
i have to do so i'm gonna be up at nine
anyway so i didn't go too hard the first
night
um but these [ __ ] guys like 8 30 in
the morning all of a sudden the stereo
just [ __ ]
comes on and i had my speaker turned off
but you know it's just you know the the
living room area
they had that you know there was no
uh the ceiling went all the way up to
the second force floor ceiling so when
you walked in the hallway upstairs
you looked off the balcony and you
looked out through these windows out to
the pool
under the water it was [ __ ] amazing
right but um
you start cranking a [ __ ] stereo
with all of that that space for all the
sounds to bounce off the [ __ ] wall
dude it sounded like a goddamn concert
right and they're cranking this [ __ ]
i'm hearing their makes start making
margaritas
[Music]
[ __ ] machine right crushing up the
ice
and all i'm thinking of is versi so i'm
laying in bed
laughing my [ __ ] ass off cause i know
first he's gonna come down those stairs
with the look on his face like he's
gonna [ __ ] murder everybody right
um and then on top of that there was a
couple of hurricane fans there and they
started doing those cheers they're out
by the pool
doing that it's great to be a miami
hurricane or
oh c-j-n-e-s kids right
screaming uh sure enough
about three minutes into this [ __ ] i get
a text from ferzi
all in capital letters he goes dude when
did the [ __ ]
orchestra start what the [ __ ]
a question mark 20 exclamation point so
i'm [ __ ] dying laughing
and uh and i'm trying to punch up the
script i'm just just you know
doing what the best i can you know this
is what happens you stay with a bunch of
other guys
you got to [ __ ] deal with other
people right so
they're doing this [ __ ] for like an hour
and a half just getting [ __ ]
loaded um
i'm trying to punch up this script and
version's losing his [ __ ] mind and
then at
right around 11 o'clock in the morning
now granted it's 11 o'clock in the
morning but we had been drinking until
like three four o'clock in the morning
there was a guitar in the house and one
of these married dudes picks this
[ __ ] thing up
he had a great voice but what the [ __ ]
right he starts
playing this thing he played like
he was playing uh bon jovi's
wanted dead or alive he's just sitting
that thing he just starts banging on the
guitar and
and you just it's like singing right in
that area where you get you know it goes
all the way up to the second floor
ceiling sitting right in the family room
they all said you just hear this guy
going it's all the same
only the names of change right
and then when he got to the chorus
somebody else was singing the richie
sambora part so he'd be like
cause i'm wanted and you hit somebody
else by the pool
[Laughter]
and all of a sudden i get a text version
he just likes
he writes really all capital letters and
then like
20 explanation points of exclamation
points
and [ __ ] question marks oh my god
dude i was laying in this bed [ __ ]
crying laughing
and every song was getting more annoying
if you were trying to sleep
this dude he [ __ ] sang paul simon's
50 ways to lose
uh leave your lover which is a [ __ ]
hilarious song because the
like the verse is like whispered and
then it gets [ __ ] loud during the
chorus like a nirvana song you know
so he's just sitting there in the living
room you know the problem is all inside
your head she said to me
the answer is easy if you take it
there must be 50 ways to leave your
lover 50 ways they leave you love and
then he just screams come on everybody
you just slip out the back jack
starts [ __ ] wailing on this guitar
um and the margarita machine was going i
just i was just [ __ ] laughing the
whole time
punching up this [ __ ] script or
whatever and uh
so then we get out there and i'm telling
you dude like nope nope
like nobody [ __ ] drinks like that
college kids i guess will drink like
that but it's understandable it's like
oh my god i'm away from my parents right
there's a different kind of desperation
that a married guy who's just [ __ ]
locked in
a married guy that doesn't cheat doesn't
[ __ ] around
you know what i mean his only outlet is
this three days that he's out there and
he is drinking
every drop of [ __ ] alcohol dude this
[ __ ] [ __ ] cannonballs into the
pool
was insane it was [ __ ] funny i
already missed it that's how much fun i
had
so anyways so after we uh we did the
show out in west palm beach
um we came back and i bought probably
the greatest assortment of cumin
cuban cigars ever amassed
by uh a redheaded balding freckled guy
46 years of age in the [ __ ] uh
west palm beach area whatever i brought
a great selection of cigars but like 25
[ __ ] cigars
i brought enough cigars so everybody the
the four people that i thought were
gonna be there
so we all could smoke three a day if we
wanted to i knew i would have some left
over
so we're huffing away late at night
laughing our balls off
me and verzi for the nine millionth time
had the matt castle
[ __ ] argument um
you know where he said the patriots made
a big mistake getting rid of the guy
dude he won 11 games and i kept going
with the team that won 16 paul that's a
five
he won five less [ __ ] games that's
like 30 percent less game so
if that team was nine and seven
thirty percent less of [ __ ] nine
games three games now that team goes six
and ten
do you understand that you just keep
looking at 11 games
ah [ __ ] drove me nuts all right then
he goes out to kc he gets hurt and they
[ __ ] cheer
midwestern classy [ __ ] people they
cheer so anyways we had that fight to
like foreign just a great
just a great hang you know
just sitting there smoking cigars out by
the pool right near the [ __ ] water
this is the greatest goddamn thing ever
and then we go to bed we wake up the
next day the [ __ ] blenders going
the guitar guy had gone home i missed
the guy man i wanted him to [ __ ] wake
up version again because it was just too
[ __ ] funny
um he had already gone home great dude
and then
um we [ __ ] uh
these guys start drinking and i'm
drinking waters
for like the first two hours i'm up i'm
drinking waters i'm doing the right
thing
and then uh i cracked open my first beer
and then i didn't want to get a beer
belly i started drinking [ __ ] crown
royal
and uh still sober
took a cab to the game everything's
going great we get out there and this is
funny thing now we go to the exact same
[ __ ] stadium
where we went and we saw those dolphin
fans all of them looking like they just
dressed like they just survived a
[ __ ] hurricane and grabbed whatever
they could put on
before they walked out honestly one of
the most depressing fan bases i've ever
seen in my [ __ ] life
the miami dolphin fans then you go to
the miami hurricane
fsu game completely night and day
unbelievably festive [ __ ] atmosphere
a bunch of young people they got their
lives ahead of them
all right good looking people it was
just great that college football spirit
people singing songs doing the chant it
was [ __ ] awesome
and um i don't know i started with the
whiskeys and i just kept going
and uh jesus christ dude
i don't know what happens to me i don't
even like the hurricanes but i get i
when i go to these games every year i
root for the [ __ ] home team
and they've yet to win
all right i went to a m alabama last
year
in uh college station alabama wins
the year before that lsu alabama
in baton rouge alabama wins year before
that i went to [ __ ] texas oklahoma
the red river game i know that they play
at the cotton bowl neutral site but it's
in texas
oklahoma wins and now this year
miami hurricanes in miami and fsu wins
i you the amount of [ __ ] fsu fans
that i [ __ ]
was giving [ __ ] to like i cared i didn't
even care
as they were doing that tomahawk chop
i was singing at the top of my lungs
genocide
you fat [ __ ] it was [ __ ] brutal
made a complete spectacle of myself
you know the hurricanes came out just
[ __ ] killing them in the first half
and you just knew you saw it you saw it
you just saw it
too much time left they had to come out
and score and they [ __ ] didn't their
field goal kicker missed an extra point
and a [ __ ] field goal you know i
can't believe any of
you [ __ ] cause he wants to get rid of
the extra point dead
like [ __ ] 99 percent of him again
it's that one percent
that adds the goddamn drama so anyways
um
i apologize to anybody who saw me at
that game and uh once again i'm on the
wagon
i still had like five cuban cigars left
and i just left them at the house i just
said
i gotta walk away from that habit um
and i'm not gonna drink or smoke until
uh
new year's day when i'm at the rose bowl
and then i'll make another spectacle of
myself
i guess you know some that guy earlier
when he was trying to say that uh
you know when i was telling him i just
had a certain level of notoriety
um i am right about that because
the my behavior at these football games
the fact that there's no cell phone
video of it
um lets you know where i'm at in this
this
this business of show oh my god you guys
i have to tell you this
story so i'm flying so i do an episode
of kroll's show
um and always working with nick crowe
you're guaranteed you're going to laugh
your ass off a [ __ ] day can i kiss
the kid's ass and he i [ __ ] love him
i think he's
i think he's a [ __ ] genius so anyways
um i go i go to the airport
and i'm taking the red eye taking this
10 55 flight non-fucking stop because
that's how i do it
all right i'm on a good plane why would
i want to get off it and switch and roll
the dice and get on another one
you know let's just [ __ ] get there
when i drive up to san francisco i don't
pull over and [ __ ] uh burbank and
then get into another car we get it bill
all right so i get on the [ __ ] plane
right
i use my miles bump myself up like a
fancy person
you know maybe maybe i invented the
cheesecake factory people are thinking
and then they see how i'm dressed and
they go oh no
he didn't vent the cheesecake factory um
and i go to go to sit down in my seat
and i go to set my bag down i was going
to set it down right in front of me and
the nice fella sit next to me because
why don't you stick it in the middle
there's room and he moved his bag out of
the way i'm like all right this guy's a
solid dude or whatever
and then all of a sudden the waitress
comes by stewardess whatever
she comes by flight attendant whatever
the [ __ ] you're supposed to call them
she comes up
and she's uh could i get you gentlemen
to drake and i was like
yeah can i get a let me get a water
please ice or no ice what
however you make it
stop acting like it's a [ __ ] martini
it's all right just give me a water
with ice thank you um
and the the guy next to me he orders the
doors neat
no ice no nothing just put it in there
so they bring our drinks
all right and i'm really thirsty so i
start sucking mine down and he just
throws his back
like it's nothing like [ __ ] john
wayne
right before he's gonna turn around and
beat up three guys
three mustachioed guys in the 1930s
right
so um i'm just sitting there and
everybody's getting on the flight you
know and i'm looking around at the
passengers
you know i'm [ __ ] doing whatever i'm
doing and all of a sudden the guy next
to me mr
doers goes to me uh he goes excuse me he
goes
are you afraid to fly
and i looked at him i was like what he
goes are you afraid to fly
and i go no no i'm not
and he goes he goes all right but you
know it's he goes it's okay
you know it's okay to tell me if you're
afraid to fly
and it's immediately getting weird and
i'm like no i'm not afraid to fly
and then i'm thinking in my head wait is
he afraid to fly
and that's why he's drinking the way he
just drank and now he's hoping that i'm
gonna be afraid to fly so he
you know he just wants to open up that's
what i'm thinking
and i'm like yeah no i'm not afraid to
fly
and he won't leave it alone he goes all
right because you know you're you're
you're fidgeting you're looking around
at other passengers and i'm sitting
there looking at like is this guy
[ __ ] serious
and i go no i go i'm not afraid to fly
so now i'm like [ __ ] this guy i'm not
talking this guy for the rest of the
flight this guy's weird man
it's like 30 just give paint to pictures
like 32 year old
wiry in shape but like wiry
white dude he's got a skully cap on with
[ __ ] glasses
um you know
and uh he goes uh
like there's like a minute of silence
and people are still getting on the
plane and then he goes
hey sorry about that sorry we just we
just got off
on the uh wrong foot he's like my name's
so-and-so he goes what's your name
and then i'm thinking in my head like
what's my name my name is frank
i wanted to give him like a by just some
reason i just wanted it's bill
and he goes oh hey billy goes nice to
meet you so we shake hands
and i'm just looking i don't have any
poker face i'm looking at the guy like
what the [ __ ] is your problem i'm not
even trying to not
i'm not trying to be pleasant i'm
already done with this guy
so then the guy goes oh hey bill he goes
why are you going to indianapolis bill
right like he's [ __ ] interrogating me
and i
i'm like is this guy [ __ ] serious and
i start doing the math in my head going
wait is this guy like an air marshal or
something and i'm like no he's not he's
[ __ ]
slamming booze over here [ __ ] this guy
so i just go i go look i don't have to
answer your questions
that's it and i just look straight
forward
he goes okay now i'm concerned okay
i am concerned and i'm looking at him
like concerned about what
he goes you're fidgeting you you have
issues with other passengers
and blah blah blah he sucks peyton like
like this like he's been
i don't know what the [ __ ] like
psychologically breaking me down
all right so now just by this point
they've closed the [ __ ]
the door to the fuselage
and we're starting the taxi
and i just finally look at the guy and i
and i go
i go you know i came up with the fight
one point i literally stick my hand out
because he kept saying i was nervous
and i stick my hand right in front of
his face and i hold it level
oh that's what i did the first time yeah
i i hold it level i go i'm not nervous
and he goes
well anybody can do that and that's when
i was like [ __ ] this guy i'm not talking
to the guy
sorry [ __ ] this story up then denny then
he came back got my name
now he's going why are you going to
indianapolis and i finally look at him i
say listen pal
i'm drinking waters you're drinking
doers
okay there's no issue over here and then
he goes it wasn't doers what she gave me
wasn't doers
really what was it some sort of spy
juice you [ __ ] jerk off
this point i want to punch him right
through his [ __ ] stupid wiry glasses
right so
he's going like you're looking around
hostels and i said something that just
ticked them off i was just yeah dude i
go i don't have to answer your questions
all right leave me alone
and then he goes uh he goes he goes he
starts going okay now i am really
concerned right now
he goes why are you going to
indianapolis and i just look at him you
know what i start doing
i start doing like this ryan gosling you
know that little smirk that [ __ ] mona
lisa smile he has as he smirks his way
through all his [ __ ] movies i do
i go full on ryan gosling now i'm not
talking to this guy
and i just keep looking at him and i
give him that little half of smirk
and i just shake my head that's my game
now
this this is mike it's like if you're
gonna be a dick right now with your
[ __ ] delusional authority
right that you're gonna like we're in
[ __ ] guantanamo and you're gonna
waterboard me huh there's no water
there's no board
go [ __ ] yourself here's my smirk and i'm
just gonna shake my head at you like
you're a [ __ ] pathetic human being
this is what i'm doing
right and this is the funny thing i'm
such a dick all i have to say to the
guys i'm a comedian i'm going to do a
sold out show there and that would make
him back off
but i'm a dick i'm like [ __ ] this guy i
want to see where this is going
so now he's all [ __ ] amped up and he
starts dropping
f you know you see saying the f word
he's sitting there going if you he goes
you don't [ __ ] answer my question
right [ __ ] now i'm gonna hit that
call button we're sitting there
taxiing down the [ __ ] getting in the
line i'm gonna [ __ ] hit this [ __ ]
button if you blah blah blah and i'm
just [ __ ] mona lisa smile smirking
just shaking my head
like you were a [ __ ] [ __ ] right
so now he's he's saying the f word so
much the lady
who's sitting in front of me diagonally
in front right in front of him turns
around and looks at us
and now my heart's racing i'm like
where's this going
this is going to be great i am 100
[ __ ] innocent
this guy's drunk and i think he's going
to hit that button
oh i got a feeling he's going to hit
that button what's going to happen right
i want to see what the pilot looks like
let's see where the [ __ ] this is going
right
so he goes if you [ __ ] you he starts he
starts bringing his hand up to the
button going i'm gonna hit that button
you don't think i'll [ __ ] do it i'll
hit that button and i'm sitting there
smirking at him thinking in my head go
ahead hit the [ __ ] button
let's see what happens let's see what
happens right so finally now he wants to
hit the button
and he can't [ __ ] find it and it's in
in defense of him
i couldn't find it either i was looking
up that i half wanted to hit it myself
then he finally he finally finds it and
he hits it
boom right and now i'm just like holy
[ __ ] what's gonna happen
and he's sitting there going yeah huh
you want to [ __ ] play this game how
you want to [ __ ] play this game
and i was surprised i mean it took like
[ __ ] like 30 seconds before
a flight attendant the one who gave him
the booze
which evidently wasn't booze comes over
and at this point
we're like doing that [ __ ] where we're
behind a plane we're almost ready to
take off like we're pulling up and then
stop and pulling up and stopping as
planes are taking off
so she goes yeah what's the problem over
here and he goes uh i'm not comfortable
to fly with this guy
this guy he's fidgeting he's looking
around at other [ __ ] people but blah
blah blah he's doing all this thing
right and then the stewardess looks at
me
and i'm just sitting there [ __ ] my
little smirk just shaking my head and i
just looking at
the dude just shaking my head like this
guy's out of his [ __ ] mind i don't
say
a word and this guy goes on and on and
on about his [ __ ] psycho babble about
how i'm the security risk
so she goes to so she goes
okay um any other passengers have you
noticed anything she's talking to
everybody first class
has anybody noticed anything odd about
this guy
and the lady who was sitting right in
front of the dude diagonally for me
turns around she goes yeah i've been
listening to this guy
berating this other passenger she's on
my side
and i even said a [ __ ] word this is
great and i'm just sitting there
smirking then the stewardess looks at me
and i shrugged my shoulders like i don't
know what to tell you
so finally she said sir do you have
anything to add to this
and i just said i look i'm just a guy
trying to go to indianapolis this guy
over here he starts slamming his doors i
kind of felt like a rat when i said that
i go slamming his doors next thing you
know he's dropping the f-bomb to me then
i'm thinking oh [ __ ]
i just said bomb right fortunately
nothing happens so now another [ __ ]
the male stewardess comes over right now
he's going like what's going on
and the captain of the [ __ ] now at
this point we pulled over and the plane
has stopped
250 people trying to get to indianapolis
and jerk off over here who can't hold
this [ __ ] alcohol
who just watched uh person of interest
every every i guess
evidently i have no [ __ ] idea now the
plane is stopped
this [ __ ] jerk-off has stopped the
plane
interrogating a goddamn comedian like
i'm in the [ __ ] taliban
and like he works for the cia right so
now we're just sitting
and the captain is up front in the plane
like
saying to the stewards is going
basically relaying do i really have to
[ __ ] come back there
this is the last flight of the night is
there really a goddamn problem
and that was the vibe and they finally
said to the douche sit next to me
are you gonna be okay to fly with him
and at that point
it appeased his [ __ ] ego
that he was somehow in control and he
goes like you know what okay
it's fine it's fine it'll be fine it'll
be fine
so they go okay so now the plane's going
again
and now now we [ __ ] come around and
he's sitting there [ __ ] he's in my
ear
and at this point i am lap like the
[ __ ] laffy hear me doing the podcast
that's what i'm doing
and he's sitting there going all right
he goes you know what i'm glad i'm glad
you st i i hope you [ __ ] do i hope
you [ __ ] try something i'll be
[ __ ] try something when we're up
there i really hope you [ __ ] try
something
and i'm just [ __ ] like gut busting
laughing
shaking me like what are you gonna
[ __ ] do to me
what are you gonna do to me how are you
gonna punch me in the face you [ __ ]
wiry jackass
with your [ __ ] glasses on you know
that's a federal offense
you're going to go to jail if you do
that or something i don't know what
right
so i'm just sitting there [ __ ]
laughing at the guy going i actually at
one point
i put my [ __ ] little eye pillow thing
on you know like i'm going to sleep
oh i had that out too when the
stewardess was talking to me i was like
putting it on is this total mind [ __ ]
like i i don't know what this guy is i'm
just trying to go to indianapolis i'm
going to sleep
and um so i got i got my [ __ ] eye
thing on
right as he's sitting there threatening
me just i was going total passive
aggressive it's like dude i'm so not
concerned with you i'm literally putting
a blindfold on
all right so this [ __ ] guy
he starts going he goes yeah he goes you
think you [ __ ] won this you think you
[ __ ] won this he goes mike you know
my dad
is my dad he started saying his dad's
some major ceo in indianapolis doesn't
sound like a [ __ ] made-up story i
swear to god this is all true
he goes mike my dad is some a major ceo
in indianapolis and i'll have you
[ __ ] arrested and the lady turns
around again i won't be [ __ ] arrested
the second weekend on the ground i'm
thinking like for what for what
sitting here you [ __ ] loser learn how
to hold your alcohol
right and he starts describing the view
that i'm gonna have when i go to jail
like some [ __ ] law and order episode
oh you're gonna love it you'll be able
to see lucas oilfield and blah blah blah
and i'm just sitting there cracking up
laughing
and then there's this pause right and
i'm thinking finally he finally shut the
[ __ ] up
it's like a three four minute pause he
finally just gave up because i wasn't
giving him anything i was just laughing
and shaking my head i was being a dick
to him i was because i was enjoying it
and then there was like a three-minute
pause and then all of a sudden he just
goes
why are you going to indianapolis bill
so we're like 20 minutes into the flight
and i gotta be honest with my adrenaline
was so going during all of that
because i knew i didn't do anything
wrong but i thought we were literally
going to go back
and there was going to be [ __ ] cops
there and like if if
if the [ __ ] stewardess or the pilot
asks me who i am and where i'm going
i'm going to tell them i respect your
authority you're just some
j i don't you don't have any [ __ ]
authority i don't have to answer your
questions
it was pr was one of the most
fun experiences i've ever had with
another human being like when somebody
thinks that they have power
and you know they don't and all they can
do
is try just keep bluffing and raising
their voice and start cursing at you and
if you just start laughing at them
the look on their face is [ __ ]
priceless
so the last thing he said he said why
are you going to indianapolis bill
right and i [ __ ] started howling just
[ __ ] holding my stomach shaking my
head
and with my [ __ ] eye pillow thing on
right
and i know i'm going to get a ton of
[ __ ] that i wear one of those i
they're [ __ ] underrated get the one
at brookstone where it's literally a
pillow
i'm telling you you could fall asleep 12
noon facing the sun
it's awesome so anyways
like after he he asked me what you know
where you're going bill
you're like it was like a 10 minute like
probably 10 minutes had gone by and i
can't [ __ ] sleep
because it's so funny to me i can't wait
to tell the story to every comic i know
i can't wait to try it on stage to see
if it's funny or whatever
uh so finally i just like i'll [ __ ] it
maybe i'll just get on my computer
and i bring up my eye pillow
and i like i gotta look at the guy
because i know he's [ __ ] staring at
me waiting for me to do
something right so i lift it up i get my
[ __ ] mona lisa smile going
and i look over at the guy and dude he
is [ __ ]
passed out
[Music]
he looked like he got shot he was
sitting there
like his head was just hanging straight
down
and anytime the plane moved like his
head was i mean he look like he got
knocked out
and for the rest of the [ __ ] flight
oh [ __ ] uh oh what's matt damon's
characters
jack ryan old [ __ ] jack ryan over
here
is just you know the sky marshall
the [ __ ] booze bag and god knows what
else he was on he was just completely
out
passed out for the rest of the [ __ ]
flight
and this is how much a dick i am i was
having so much fun with this guy i start
i can't sleep so i start slamming waters
because i want to have to get up and
take a piss just to see if this guy's
going to freak out
because this security risk is getting up
and this the joke was on me he never
regained consciousness and then i really
had to take a piss but i'm such a
stubborn
[ __ ] i was holding it because i wanted
to make sure he was awake when i got up
because i was going to give him a little
smirk and then i was going to get up
see if he hit the call button again um
but he did he didn't wake up till we we
hit the ground
and um and then it's funny then he woke
up it was like four hours later so now
he had kind of slept off whatever the
[ __ ] this guy was on
and i'm sitting there smirking waiting
for the guy to start talking he won't
look at me
and i and i think at that point he kind
of [ __ ] realized that maybe he got a
little uh
a little extra little too patriotic
so we stop we stop at the gate and
everything and we're going to get up so
i grab my [ __ ]
i get up and i'm just kind of looking at
him and he won't look at me
and then the lady who was sitting in
front of me had this big smile on her
face she goes how you
she goes how are you doing i went good i
go that i go that was an interesting one
and i said it really loud so the guy
heard
and he didn't say anything and this is
what he did to try to save face
his pillow was kind of stuck behind was
kind of stuck behind his shoulder in
like a weird place
so he was frustrated with it so he
ripped it out from behind him and kind
of threw it down on the floor went
like he tried to do some caveman grunt
to try to still have some sort of uh
i don't know what so so that was my
flight to indianapolis people
um you know what how far into the
[ __ ] podcast are we that was a long
that was a long [ __ ] story speaking
of uh
physical harm the lovely nia
um last night she um
she like bent down to get something out
of her bag and there's this little
[ __ ] ledge
above it that she can stick like a
couple of glasses in a bottle of water
and she was underneath it bent down came
up full speed
and the corner of it hit the [ __ ] top
of
she hit the top of her head right on the
corner of it
like brutally hard
and um i gotta tell you i feel bad that
she's
not part of this [ __ ] little story
here see if i'll bring her in because i
failed miserably
as a human being nia do you want to be
in on this story of you hitting your
head
okay i okay i'm setting it up now so
anyway she [ __ ] hits her head
like [ __ ] bam all right
sounded like somebody dropped a suitcase
on the floor
and then i swear to god she hit her head
she goes
ah she grabbed her head and then i swear
to god
she just started crying
like a goddamn toddler
and i have to be honest with you
i didn't know what the [ __ ] to do i just
got to the point near where you hit your
head
and you started crying like a toddler
and why is it gonna be like it's hot
because that's what it reminded me of
like when a little kid
like an adult hits their you know stubs
their toe hits their foot is god damn
[ __ ] yeah then you blame your
whole family get out of the living room
you know that's what you do
you started crying i did
it was really painful like balling
yeah and uh i was honest
on a scale of one to five five being the
best five
how would you no no how would you rate
my reaction to oh zero
i went in and i got you some tissues
this is what bill did
i didn't know what to do it freaked
my head boom i was shocked at it first
because it really did feel like
someone had just come up and just walked
me on the noggin
so i was shocked then the pain started
kicking in
and like it was really like it was like
that little
it was it was that corner of that ledge
and it wrote right into my scalp
and i didn't know if i was bleeding or
what and i i think yeah normally i'd be
like
like most people but i just i don't know
what happened just the floodgates open
and it felt better to cry
than to pretend like it was just like oh
like a nuisance like it really really
hurt
so bill's like oh no are you okay
so we're good so what else was i
supposed to do so we're good so far
with that okay so i'm just sitting there
crying
and he goes oh and he runs into the
bathroom
he doesn't even give me a tissue like a
proper cleaning
he gets me toilet paper okay
if there is a choice between tissue
paper and toilet paper to comfort
someone
please find the kleenex okay it's softer
it's just
you know it's just it's a little thing
but it makes a big difference it's a
cutter
so then he starts wiping my face
with the toilet paper
he's rubbing it on my face i don't know
when he's wiping my [ __ ] he's doing like
this u-shape
from my eye to the other eye using my
chin
that's like to go between
[Laughter]
toilet paper back and forth across
my chin and he's going
big tears pixie they were huge
and it's like i never seen anybody cry
too what is that supposed to mean
whether big tears big tears it wasn't
like
oh baby you know it was he was just
scraping my face you gotta be honest
with this toilet paper going
big tears
i gotta be honest with you it was
[ __ ] it freaked me out
it was the worst moment of comforting
you've ever
offered in your life yeah you had a
complete loss for what to do because it
was like you stopped being like a woman
and you became like this
two-year-old and it was just like boom
you're just like
damn i was just like
i didn't know what to do if we were at
home i would have got you a popsicle or
something oh and then you said do you
want some
water what what the [ __ ] does water have
to do with anything
that's what my parents always did if you
hurt yourself and you cried they went
and they got your water right out of the
chat
then you sat down and then your face was
all dried and salty and they said all
right go back outside again
that's it i spent most of my childhood
outside that's what parents did all
right get outside all right you kids
you're driving me nuts get outside
and you just set them outside that's
what you wanted to do with me in that
moment you wanted to send me away so you
wouldn't have to deal with it anymore i
just wanted you to stop [ __ ] crying
i don't mean that in a bad way but it's
just like to see another adult
can you imagine if i if i ever hit my
[ __ ] head and started
crying the way you did i mean what would
you know what would be coming out of
your mouth
i don't know i'd be like come here baby
and i'd hold you to my chest
or whatever and i'd rub your back you're
full of [ __ ] if i [ __ ] hit my head
and started crying like a little
girl was it really that
like it was like a little it was like a
little uh it was
yeah i've known you for 12 years i've
never seen you i've seen you like
you see me cry before a couple times in
the kitchen you [ __ ]
you know you cut yourself with the knife
and even then you didn't cry as much
that was like
you know you had a balloon and the thing
went off your wrist and floated up in
the air
there was just no comfort in you it was
uh yeah i'm ready i'll admit
um not only did i drop the ball in that
moment
it's been 24 hours and i still don't
have a better approach
it was so [ __ ] bizarre don't ever do
that again neil
all right what do you thought the thing
is the really
sort of horrible thing about it the the
biggest injustice of it all
the fact that you weren't able to
comfort me is that i was trying to plug
in
your [ __ ] computer isn't that amazing
is it amazing i knew somehow it would
come back to me
and it'd be my fault that your dumb ass
ducked underneath the ledge and then
lifted your head up ric flair wouldn't
have done it that hard to sell a [ __ ]
move
i didn't realize it was there i was
plugging in your computer
and you got the audacity to be the worst
comforting person in that moment ever
scratching my face with that one-ply
toilet paper
while saying big tears big tears which
is like
what does that even mean it's like it
was
out in the outfield a little league
again no better no better big tears big
tears
just kept saying big tears over and over
again what did that mean
you're just commenting on it i
i i didn't i didn't know what to do i
mean you were crying at a [ __ ] level
like i mean i've been at funerals and
seen people cry that's
what the [ __ ] you were doing i didn't
know what to do okay i'm
sorry you caught me off guard well tell
me what am i supposed to say
just give me a [ __ ] you're just
supposed to like you know take me into
your arms and like hold me
and like you know rub my back or
something that sounds like a commercial
for one of those
love songs like time life presents
it doesn't seem like a real thing that
people do well i'm telling you that's
what i would like you asked me
so i'm telling you what i would like i'd
like your sunglasses to not be so big
how about that i'm chatting jackie oh on
this trip
jackie oh jesus
[Music]
if you ever hit your head again and
start crying like a two-year-old
just give me kleenex okay that's all i
ask
don't give me toilet paper deal i don't
have to say anything
what do you mean you don't have to say
anything you have to comfort me
jerk give me three things to say are you
okay
come here it's gonna be all right
you cried way longer than that
yeah and you just have to like come keep
saying that are you gonna be okay
come here it's going to be all right how
disconnected are you from human emotion
that i have to teach you how to comfort
somebody
crying was a sign of weakness where i
came from okay
wow that was a long time the [ __ ] up
well
man or woman you did you know
i don't you know what happened to me
that was the first time i cried
all right you know what happened you
know what i'm really tired of hearing
about your
slapped in the face and giving a bud
light
rockwellian childhood or whatever it is
that you're always describing
they stuck your head under the water of
an above-ground pool
until they stop seeing bubbles and they
pull you back up again
like you really like paint a picture
like you grew up in like this hard
scrabble kind of [ __ ] environment and
you didn't
you don't think so you fell out of a
tree and your parents are like
shake it off okay that is what happened
though right
what didn't you was it you that fell out
of a tree
no i got hit by a car oh right you got
it by the car
you poor baby and my parents sent away
the ambulance because they didn't like
the hospital they were taking us to
and i got in a cab and they took us to
the hospital they wanted to remember my
mother
kept telling me don't go to sleep don't
go to sleep oh no wonder
okay all right well i get it now no ne
i'm not saying i [ __ ] grew up in a
slum
i'm just saying it was it was different
back then
it was okay yeah it was different all
right well
yeah that's all i'm saying i'm not
saying i'm a [ __ ] badass but like i
i'm not going to apologize for having a
[ __ ] up world view okay
adults taught me this [ __ ] so all right
yeah go talk to them
i'll talk to your parents about it yeah
i don't know just anybody roughly there
right
with you yeah but you know something
near there wasn't over correction
meaning one that there's a reason why
it went from [ __ ] walled up douches
like me who only know how to go oh
big tears big tears i grab toilet paper
and make a u-shaped [ __ ] sign around
your face
that we went from that to those [ __ ]
hipster
hoodie wearing beard [ __ ] bearded
[ __ ] [ __ ]
who act like they're 14 years old and
awkward on their first [ __ ] day
every generation think that they're
tougher than like the next generation
is that just what happens i don't think
i'm tougher than anybody
previous to me and i don't feel like i'm
tougher than anybody
like anybody now that there's so many
[ __ ] places in
just the united states alone where kids
grow up way tougher than i did
but what i'm doing is i'm defending the
fact that i don't know what to do when
an
adult hits their [ __ ] head and cries
like a two-year-old
all right i'm not trying to have some
like olympics backstory here
before you watch me play ping pong or
some other stupid [ __ ] sport that
nobody cares about
the next thing oh here's a great story
for you brian you might like this do you
know i was a hero this week
really i was actually i did something
heroic
i have never i have never done anything
heroic
in my life okay and believe me i've
walked by house fires
and saw people screaming saying there's
a ladder right there
just put it up and i walked away i
walked away
pretended like i didn't hear him i'm
that kind of a [ __ ] guy um
no this is the deal it was uh sunday
and you know people go to brunch on
sunday i'm like all right [ __ ] it i'll
go to brunch
i'll go to brunch right remember that
bit huh pace eighteen dollars is that as
fast is that asbestos how did that bit
go
is that i thought it was pesto it's
asparagus i can't remember
so we go to brunch and uh you know it's
usual [ __ ] do you want to sit inside you
want to sit out
outside as a redhead i'm always going
inside let's [ __ ] sit inside i got
enough freckles i've had enough [ __ ]
pain in my life
please let's sit inside
but you know i'm always with broads
because they always want to go to brunch
let's sit outside it's so nice it's
always [ __ ] nice when they go to
brunch it's never raining is it
right so all right let's sit outside so
we sit outside
and because i'm the gentleman i have to
sit with my back to the road so i can
brace
you know and protect my girlfriend and
her mom in case a bread truck comes
flying in because the guy's text
messaging or something right
so i'm sitting there and uh
all of a sudden i just feel it i just
feel like something's [ __ ] wrong and
something
my caveman dna like when you're getting
stalked
by a saber-toothed tiger just kicks in
and something just tells me
to [ __ ] look left and i look left and
here comes this crazy [ __ ] lady and
i'm talking
crazy i'm talking shutter island you
remember that chick that shushed
leonardo dicaprio is that the second
leonardo dicaprio [ __ ] reference
there you go you remember that chick who
shushed him in shutter island
that's what this girl looked like except
with sort of brownish red hair
okay it's basically one of these people
who should be getting professional help
is straight up bat [ __ ] crazy and
uh this just this state is bankrupt so
they just let them go
they just let these [ __ ] people go
you know see sarah mclaughlin whining
about these people
come out and rescue these [ __ ] the
these people who are talking to
telephone poles it's all about the dogs
with her
her priorities are so [ __ ] up it's
ridiculous i hope she sees this
i am so disappointed in you sarah
mclaughlin
huh when are you gonna grow up and stop
whining about those little
pussy-ass [ __ ] dogs
all right that was mean all right let's
get back to it so she starts coming down
the street and she's like she looks like
she's gonna start [ __ ] crying
okay like and it's just one of those
things you know you just feel this
[ __ ] person's gonna do something and
i have a feeling
they're gonna do it to me so i'm i'm
working out my [ __ ] i'm like
first fortunately the chairs were these
really light wicker sort of kind of
douchey brunchy chairs so i was just
gonna grab the [ __ ] chair
and i was gonna smash her in the face if
i didn't have time
or if i had time i was gonna leap to my
feet on my bad [ __ ] foot
and out like a lion tamer ah get back
crazy person right
[Laughter]
start whipping her with the [ __ ]
tulips on the nice beautiful brunch
table
that's what i was gonna do so she
doesn't lunge at me but she walks by me
is that awful moment the blind spot
you know what i mean where she's not to
my left she's not to my right she's
right behind me and she [ __ ] goes by
me and i'm like thank god like i was
seriously [ __ ] nervous
and i look left again just you know
i don't know why i look left again and
then i see this [ __ ]
sad looking woman slowly following the
crazy person
with this look on her face like she had
been wronged
next thing i know next thing i [ __ ]
know
she's talking to the table next to us
and talking to us talking about how that
crazy woman had just walked up to her
reached up to her sweater and just
[ __ ] ripped
i don't know she had a brooch she just
[ __ ] took it off her
chest and walked away with it and i'm
looking at the lady
and she has the lady and she has this
[ __ ] hole
in her sweater where something had
clearly been ripped off
and for the life of me i don't know why
i immediately just got up
i don't know why i have no [ __ ] idea
why the [ __ ] i don't do this [ __ ]
i get up and now i'm going down the
street following
the shutter island lady with no training
whatsoever
in this situation i'm literally walking
and now i couldn't sit down
i couldn't get sit down like i have this
this [ __ ]
lee marvin i'm gonna i'm gonna make [ __ ]
right
moment and then i go you know what maybe
i'll sit down i look at the biggest
[ __ ] ever
and not only my girlfriend there my
mother's there so i had to keep going so
now i'm following this girl
and i'm literally
i've never been so [ __ ] nervous in my
life because it would have been bad
enough if it was like a crazy dude
a crazy guy is scary but at least you
know if if if it gets physical
i mean what what are the rules in that
do you know
brian what you know you can't hit a
woman but what if she's crazy and she
just stole a brooch
how about a jab just gonna get her mitt
in the face like larry holmes so she
doesn't see the overhand right gun
anyways i don't know what to do so
but i can't go back to the table or i'm
gonna look like a [ __ ] in front of my
girlfriend and my mom so i'm like
[ __ ] why did i get up why did i get up
why didn't i just why didn't i say
sit inside i wanted to sit inside but i
didn't want to seem like a rude prick
in front of my girlfriend's mom like i
tell her what to do like she's this kept
[ __ ] woman
so now i'm in this situation so i'm
walking down the street and this is what
i do
she's on the sidewalk i'm literally in
the street
okay i'm like is that circumnavigation
i'm doing some police [ __ ]
where i'm staying outside of whatever
she can throw at me scratching it's one
of these people
you got to get like a tetanus shot if
you roll around the ground or hepatitis
or some [ __ ]
so i'm like what am i going to do what
do i do so i don't know what happened i
just said
i i basically i just started going hey
uh hey sweetheart hey sweetie i
i basically i think i started calling
her affectionate names from like the
1940s
hey uh [ __ ] tall drink of water and i
finally
got her attention and she turns around
and looks at me with this crazy
look with tears in her eyes and i just
say uh
i i i think you have something that
doesn't belong to you and meanwhile
there's a [ __ ] pathetic lady who
just let her walk up to her to begin
with it's like he didn't see that she
was crazy that's why i'm in this
situation right
she [ __ ] she ends up walking up to
the girl and
when i said i think you have something
that doesn't belong to you she just sort
of looked at me like in slow motion
lifted up her left arm and she had this
green pea soup looking sweater on
and she had the broach pinned to like
just right around her wrist and she just
held it up
so at this point i'm like i'm not
touching this [ __ ]
[Music]
so i let the the [ __ ] victim lady
with the sad puppy dog eyes
she comes in and i'm basically sitting
there like an nhl
ref with respect for two goons that are
about ready to go at it
right and i'm just gonna jump in when i
see
that i can jump in to stop this this
fight that's gonna happen without
getting
hit myself and uh so anyways the lady
starts un
unpinning the brooch and the whole time
she's she basically followed my lead
by being nice she just kept going thank
you i really appreciate it
i really appreciate this and she
couldn't get the [ __ ] thing off
it was like one of those action movies
where like the clock's going down for
the bomb
and i'm sitting there going lady in my
head i'm like would you get
that [ __ ] brooch off this crazy
bitch's arm and i just kept looking at
her right hand because i knew
at some point she was either gonna gouge
her eye out just do some crazy [ __ ]
right like you know that the scrap metal
that these people put pick up
and floss their teeth with she was just
gonna stick her right in the jugular
so finally long story short she gets the
[ __ ] broach off
and then we we we back away
it was like uh exchange like we like we
gave some money
briefcase and we got the abducted kid
back and we [ __ ] walk away
and i'm like oh [ __ ] thank god thank god
that worked out i actually walked back
to the to the brunch
all right walked back to the brunch and
i got a [ __ ] applause break
from like all these people eating eggs
benedict and eggs florentine was [ __ ]
awesome
i was a goddamn hero this week people
a scared nervous [ __ ] hero
dude i'm telling you brian i didn't come
within seven feet of this woman